(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link!
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we're gonna be talking about some stuff
that is making us laugh
right now in our lives.
- And I'll expand that
to what makes us laugh,
and what doesn't make us laugh?
I think that...
I've been trying to figure that out,
as I've pulled together
some thoughts about this.
We've talked about it between
the two of us in the past,
just trying to figure out what it is
that tickles our funny bones,
and what are the type of things we avoid.
And I just wonder if there's some
conclusions to draw from that.
- Well, and I think...
I don't know, I always find
it interesting... (chuckles)
I'm putting myself in
your shoes, listening.
I always find it interesting
to listen to people
who do a particular thing for a living.
Like, I guess one way you could distill
what we do for a living
is we make people laugh,
you know-
- Hopefully.
- That's one of the main things
that we're doing is we're trying
to make people laugh.
- I think we elicit other
emotions and reactions
along the way.
- Yeah, they may scratch
their heads or whatever.
- But that's the main,
that's the main outcome,
desired outcome.
- But I find it interesting
when people who do something for a living
sorta talk about how they
perceive those things in society
and how they enjoy the
thing that they provide,
the service that they provide.
It's almost like, you
got somebody who's like,
"Yeah, you know Tom. You
know Tom, at Tom's Burgers?
"He makes a good burger,
but do you know where he
actually really loves to eat?"
- Oh yeah, what type of
burger does Tom like to eat?
- Does Tom like to eat his burgers
more than he likes to eat Judy's burgers?
And this is not a
euphemism; get your minds
out of the gutter.
- I thought...
Isn't there a Tom-
- There is a Tom's.
- And there's a Tom number two.
That's something that
happens in L.A. is that-
- There's actually a lot-
- You'll have a restaurant-
- There's a Tommy's.
There's a Tommy's, which is-
- Well, Tommy's is a chain.
- Tommy's is a chain that
does burgers and Mexican food.
It's been around for a long time.
- But there's some other places
that are not quite chains.
They're just big enough to have numbers.
There's Chinese restaurants and
some burger/taco restaurants
around L.A. that are like, I've seen...
For a Chinese restaurant,
I've seen probably up to
maybe number four, you know?
There's Frontier Wok, and
then there's Frontier Wok Too.
- I think when you get to number five
is when you start just
saying, "You know what?
We don't have to number these anymore."
- But yeah, I know what you're saying.
I wanna ask my mailman, you know,
"How do you feel when you get mail?
Do you get, I mean, does
Amazon come to your house?
How do you feel about that?"
- Does a mail person-
- Deliver their own mail?
Or no, is that against the law?
- You know...
(Rhett laughing)
- That also sounds like a euphemism.
- Don't shit where you eat, man.
- Don't deliver your own mail.
Don't get caught delivering your own mail.
This is kinda getting back
to our sorting the mail.
You wanna sort the mail-
- Oh, well, you're gonna wanna
hold onto that a little bit-
(Rhett laughing)
- You wanna sort the mail.
- Given something I got for you.
- With someone else.
You can sort the mail yourself!
There's no shame in that.
We were raised to think
that there was shame
in sorting your own mail;
there's no shame in it!
It's one of the most natural things.
- This is, well, you know what?
- But delivering your own
mail, that's crossing the line.
(Rhett laughing)
- Okay, we're going here.
I have something for
you, and it's kinda crazy
that you're already on this track.
- That I'm on mail?
- Well, okay, so just put a pause to that.
Just clear your mind.
- I can't do that.
- I'm not gonna try to make
a segue because that will...
There's something I wanna share with you
that's not related to what makes us laugh,
but I wanted to go ahead and put it
at the top of the episode.
And I could make a grand
segue, but instead,
I'd rather just kinda tabula
Rosa, clear the slate.
- Oh, tabula Rosa. Somebody's
been watching a documentary!
- (laughs) What, on Latin?
(Rhett laughing)
Latin and philosophy?
- Well, you didn't take a Latin class!
- No, I didn't. I've been
watching documentaries.
- Right.
(Link laughing)
- No, I know what the term tabula...
That's just part of my vocabulary, man!
- You did pay attention in vocabulary.
You did very well in vocabulary.
I remember thinking about how well
you were doing in vocabulary.
- Well, it's very binary.
You either know it or you don't.
- I was like, "Link's really into these
vocabulary books that Miss..."
Who would've given those to us,
that class we would have been in?
They were smaller than
the other textbooks.
It was a smaller book.
- It was the AG vocabulary books.
So if you were academically gifted,
you got an additional vocabulary book
and it had like bigger words
in it, and you were kinda...
And I took pride in that.
But listen, that's not
what I wanna talk about.
I wanna talk about...
It's been a while since Valentine's Day,
but Christy got me something
for Valentine's Day,
and I keep meaning to bring
it in and show it to you.
And I have it with me now.
And there's no pressure for you
to immediately know what this thing is.
In fact, I hope you don't immediately
know what it is.
- Well, I watch a lot
of documentaries.
(Link chuckling)
So I know a lot of things.
- When she gave it to me,
there was a process of discovery
that I had to go through
to appreciate what this was
and how to incorporate it
into my personal life.
She bought one for herself
and she bought one for me.
I have the one that she bought for me
in my pocket right now.
- Oh, so it's small!
- I'm gonna give it to you,
and I just kinda want...
I'm kinda hoping that you
can have a similar experience
than the one I had when I
opened Christy's Valentine
(laughs) gift for me.
- This is the only thing she got you?
- It's the only thing
I'm willing to share.
- Oh, okay, all right.
- And you may think, "If
he's willing to share this,
what is he hiding?"
- Hmm, okay.
- All right?
So, maybe close your eyes, and you know,
I wanna recognize that
for the video version,
you're gonna get to see this,
but we'll try to paint
the best picture possible
for just you audiophiles.
- Okay, I've got my
eyes closed and now I've got my hand out.
- Okay.
Let me balance it a
little bit on your palm.
- What?
- Kinda cup it, yeah, there you go.
Ah, I can't get it to stand up!
Okay, there it is, (chuckles)
that is my Valentine's gift from my wife.
Maybe you should just
start off by describing it
for our listeners-only.
- Is the stand part of it?
- That's the stand,
so you can just put the stand
down here.
- Why is it oily and wet?
Okay, so-
- 'Cause I've used it.
- All right, it looks like...
It has the shape of a...
One side looks like a microphone.
It's like a circular thing-
- It's got a circular head on it.
- But then it has sort of a handle
that if I just did this,
I mean, I can't...
There's only one thing that I know-
- What's it made out of?
- It's made out of silicone, like rubber.
- Or Silicon, depending on who you are,
and how you talk about it.
Push the button.
- Well, I'm sure it's gonna vibrate.
(device humming)
- Yeah, hold that up to the
mic, and let's get some...
- It's a vibrator.
- Well, it vibrates.
- But that doesn't...
I'm just saying that in a technical term.
- Push it again.
(device humming loudly)
More intense.
- And then it's got, yeah,
this is a typical vibrator
in that it's got different speeds,
and then-
- It's pulsing.
- There's a pulsating, then
there's a fast pulsate.
- Yes, and then-
- And then it goes off.
- And it's off-
- There's four speeds.
- And you can put it in this...
You can put it in that stand
and it'll sit upright for you
and stare at ya-
- Uh, okay.
- When you're not using it.
It's got a neck, it's
got a round head on it,
and it's got a slender neck-
- It's got a neck
that can be positioned.
- That bends.
Now, don't be too rough with it.
- Why is it so oily on the bottom?
- 'Cause I've been using it.
So yeah, it vibrates.
Christy's is pink and mine is black.
- Okay, well, I'll say a couple of things.
If you were to, I'm sure...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
I'm sure it can be used...
If you wanted to sort your own mail,
you could do it with this.
(Link laughing)
But I am very convinced that there's
so many better options for that.
I mean, the fact that it's got
these little nodules on it,
(sighs) from a scientific standpoint,
I would say that this is...
And there's a hair on it, which is a clue.
- Mm, okay, sure, pick those off.
That's fine.
- What kinda hair is that?
(Link laughing)
Is it an exfoliation device?
- It is a facial cleanser.
PMD is the brand.
She wouldn't tell me how
much she paid for this thing.
I think it was over $100,
and-
- Well, that's a rip-off.
- And basically,
what I'm trying to tell you
is, for Valentine's Day,
Christy gave me a vibrator
to rub on my face.
- Right, a face vibrator.
(both laughing)
(stutters) A face vibrator.
- Vibrator. (laughs)
I mean, I've never had
a gift like that before!
And sometimes we'll do
it in sync, like, well,
over our sinks, at the same time,
in tandem.
- The idea is that
this is better than your hands
because it's gonna exfoliate,
it's gonna shake dead skin loose?
- I've got a manual face brush that I use
in the shower-
- But, okay-
- To exfoliate and-
- But what is the-
- She's saying this is better.
- Well, I'll tell you why
she thinks it's better.
'Cause I-
- Marketing! That's why!
- I guarantee you-
- Instagram marketing, period!
- No, it has nothing to do with the world,
it has everything to do with
you, Link Neal in particular,
and what it's like to know
you and experience with you.
Now, what is the brush in
the shower made out of?
- Bristles?
- Okay.
- I bought it myself.
- Right. I have zero doubt.
I would bet every dime I've
ever seen or will ever see
that you brush your face too
aggressively with this brush.
- I thought you were gonna
say that bacteria grew on it,
which is also true.
They say that this thing is, like,
antibacterial, or whatever.
- I'm just saying that
Christy has probably observed you
brushing your face with that brush,
and she's worried, as she should be,
because whenever you get
to cleaning or touching,
or basically, everything
that you decide to do,
you do very aggressively.
- So you're saying
I don't exfoliate, I maxfoliate.
- Yeah, I'm saying that
your exfoliation is clearly,
definitely, without a
doubt, too aggressive.
I mean, you fricking
got told by your dentist
that you were brushing
your teeth too hard.
- The first thing I did notice was that,
because you grabbed this bottom bulb,
and there's a little skinny-
- It gives.
- It has a give to it, and I was thinking,
this has not got enough scrub to it.
- (laughs) Exactly! It does, though!
Because you don't have to-
- This is not
what I wanna talk about.
- You don't have to-
- I agree with this.
- (laughs) Okay.
- Listen, I agree-
- Your wife saved your face!
- The reason why she got...
She got one for herself, too.
The reason why, it is marketing.
It's an anti-aging face vibrator!
Because you know, they say things like,
"Oh, it gives you, it exfoliates,
it doesn't scrub too
hard, it's antibacterial,"
but basically, it's just to put something
on your face to just, like...
It's supposed to be
more of a deep-cleaning-
- Well, we're in the age of vibration.
- Everything vibrates now!
- We're in the age of vibration.
Your toothbrush vibrates,
your face brush vibrates.
- And let me tell you, my-
- There's only one thing
that actually needs to vibrate.
- What?
- A actual vibrator.
Because if that doesn't vibrate-
- I don't know-
- That can be a problem.
- When I got this, and for
the first couple weeks,
I was totally prepared
to just come in here
and make fun of it, which
I've done to this point,
but now I'm gonna add a
little something, which is,
I might start liking it.
I really, you know, my battery
went dead in my toothbrush.
Quip is a sponsor, not currently
a sponsor, I don't think,
but so be it.
- They'll come back around.
- I'm on board with the Quip.
When the battery ran out, I
was like brushing manually,
and I really felt like
it wasn't doing the job!
- Is that why your dentist was like,
"You're brushing too
hard," and you were like,
"Well, my toothbrush
stopped vibrating." (laughs)
- I think it-
- "I had to make up for it."
- My teeth have improved from that point,
but it is a bit strange
to just rub a vibrator all over your face.
But I just wanted you to know
that every night I'm doing that.
And if you think about me,
that's what I want you to picture.
- Well, I'm not going to
be thinking about that.
Have you rubbed, have you vibe...
Have you put it anywhere else?
- No, but-
- 'Cause that's what would
be a problem with me.
- I also think that this is
kind of a back door, (laughs)
you know, for someone who is associating
some stigma with self-pleasure, and hey,
we wanna remove any stigma
we can with self-pleasure,
which is the thing that you
were talking about (chuckles)
before I even brought this
thing out of my pocket!
- Right.
- By the way, you can
keep it in your pocket
very discreetly and you can
carry it with you anywhere.
- I talk about self-pleasure
at least once a day,
it's just, it usually doesn't happen
on this podcast.
- I think I'm going to be,
like, whenever I start
traveling and stuff,
you'll see me in airport bathrooms
using this vibrator on my face.
You know how you see people-
- But you have to use it
with soap, right?
- Brushing their teeth?
Yeah, I put a little
dollop of face stuff there.
It's an anti-aging
thing that's supposed to
make you look more youthful,
and you know, that's just-
- There's no shame in that!
- That marketing is irresistible.
- You know, I've been exfoliating
for the past two years,
and having never done it before,
but it doesn't vibrate, it's just a thing,
it's just a thing I scrub
on my face with my hands,
you know what I'm saying?
- What else needs a vibrator?
- I mean, I move my hands
very quickly when I do it.
- That's what I'm trying to figure out,
like the seat in my car will vibrate.
I'm trying to...
There's gotta be something
that doesn't currently vibrate
that we can vibratize
and just revolutionize the market.
- I've got ideas of
just a vibrating shirt.
- Oh!
- Just a shirt, it's
kind of like the shirts
that make your dogs feel-
- Comforted.
- The tight shirts.
- Secure. Yes!
- How 'bout, it's a vibrating shirt.
- A tight vibrating shirt. That's-
- I think you can
vibrate too much, though.
- That's getting close to, still,
massage of places that you would massage.
Like if the shirt's really tight,
even if you inflate it a little
bit to make it really tight,
and then the massage kicks in,
I'm sure people have thought of that.
But I'm thinking of something else that-
- I think a vibrating comb-
- Like a vibrating bed
is something that's been
in motels for, you know, decades.
A vibrating comb.
- A vibrating comb,
so, you know, because I've got
this wavy hair that gets...
I mean, literally, I cannot, and you know,
if you've got hair like
mine or anything curlier,
you can't just take a comb
and just comb the hair.
The structure of the hair,
you can't run a comb through my hair,
without pulling a bunch of it out.
So the only way I can comb my hair,
and I've never had to comb my hair,
'cause it's never been this long,
is-
- Is with a vibrator.
- Is one of those wet brushes.
So I literally, the
only time I comb my hair
is in the shower, while
there's conditioner in my hair.
- Oh, wow.
- Get all the conditioner
in my hair and I work all
the knots out of my hair.
And by the way, I pull so much hair out,
like enough hair to sell
to the Hair Club for Men
to make a hair for a bald man.
- Oh, that's scary, innit?
- Like, every time.
And I only do that like twice a week,
because it takes so
long; I don't have time!
- Well, you might run outta hair!
- If that, you know, this is waterproof,
you make that brush vibrate,
and it's gonna work its way through the...
You know what, I bet you,
you could look on Amazon
right now and find-
- Or at least feel good.
- Vibrating brush is
probably already a thing.
It's not, let's file a patent right now.
- Vibrating pillow?
- That might get old.
- I mean, you definitely can't
read a book or your phone,
like, with your head resting
on a vibrating surface.
- Vibrating pen.
- So you look like a
nervous writer? (chuckles)
- No, no, it vibrates very
quickly and it makes the...
I bet you it would make
the process of writing
even more enjoyable.
- No.
- Maybe increase your stamina,
and also make the ink come
out even more uniform.
A vibrating pen.
- Vibrating underwear.
- Well, that exists.
- What?
- Yeah, that exists, man!
I can tell you a lot of things exist.
I go to those websites.
- Are you talking about Adam & Eve?
- Yeah, Adam & Eve, and
there's other ones like that.
Yeah, you can get vibrating underwear.
I mean, basically it's
just a pair of underwear
that has a little
vibrator pocket in there.
I mean, that's exciting.
Yeah, I'm into it.
But that's been done.
We're not gonna win any awards for that.
Invent America is not gonna give Johnny
a scholarship for that.
- I remember there's that
website, mypleasure.com.
Not a sponsor.
- That's another one.
- That's a good one.
There's no pornographic
images on that website.
So if you wanna avoid those,
if that's not your cup of tea,
then you can go there and
you can get your bedroom toys
and you don't have to
worry about seeing things
that you don't wanna see,
if that's your thing
that you don't wanna see.
Also not a sponsor, but hey, shout-out.
I think they're still in business.
- I mean, not having the
real people on the website,
it's probably hurting
the business. (laughs)
But like you said, maybe
there are people who...
I mean, I kinda wanna see how fits,
do you know what I'm saying?
- You're usin' that term.
- (laughs) I kinda wanna know like, well,
how does this actually
relate to the human body?
(Link chuckling)
You know, how do-
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
- How do these vibrating
underwears go on?
Is it one leg through each hole?
In the waist at the top? (laughs)
- But there's nothing...
Let's see, I mean, 'cause, like,
your XBOX controller
vibrates, your freakin'...
Everything vibrates!
I mean, is there nothing
that we can come up with
that we can get excited about?
- I think the comb is not a bad idea, but-
- The comb is not a bad idea.
- But I think-
- We got a musical comb.
- It probably exists.
- But is it musical vibratory?
All right.
- Well, we could talk
about that all day.
- All right.
I'm gonna put this back in my pocket.
- Yeah, just don't vibrate it
while we're talking, please.
We also-
- In my jacket pocket,
(laughs) not my pants pocket.
- We don't have anything
that vibrates in the Mythical Store,
but we do have magical mugs
that change color when you put...
They're heat activated!
When you put a hot beverage
in there, it creates a scene.
- Mine has hot tea.
- That is related
to the "Good Mythical Morning" intro.
- It is revealing the scene,
but I can tell you right now,
one of the things about
this is that when you put
your hot drink, your coffee,
your tea in this thing,
you can get an indication
that it's starting to cool,
that you need to get back
to it before it gets tepid.
You know, I'd rather drink all
my coffee in some big gulps
while it's still warm than discover
that I've got a third of
my coffee and it's tepid.
And this gives you a visual
representation of that.
So it's not just that it is the coolest,
most magical mug you've ever seen,
but it is also functional and it vibrates.
- And here's one of the things
- No, it doesn't.
- A lot of people have asked,
"How is it that on
'Good Mythical Morning,'
whoever has the heat-activated mug,
it just stays hot all the time?"
Well, a little inside information-
- That's a secret.
- The one I have is always
activated to give the appearance
that it always has something hot in it.
The one that Link is currently
using is an authentic one,
which is why you see
that the top of his flame
is already fading; look
at the top of my flame.
It will never fade. So
yeah, it is trickery.
- And if you're a member
of the Mythical Society,
you already knew that because
we answered it in an AMA.
We give all types of secrets over there.
- Mm, double-add, yeah,
mythicalsociety.com.
- And mythical.com to get
your magical mug needs met.
Rep ya boys.
- Okay!
- What makes us laugh?
My contribution to this episode
is gonna be more philosophical than...
And I think the list that you have,
I'll have some camaraderie on that,
because you actually made a list of things
that are currently
making you laugh, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, I made some things
that more historically have made me laugh,
have made us laugh,
that I'd like to analyze.
- Yeah, I'm not, yeah.
My stuff is not...
Nothing really, maybe except
one, is current, (chuckles)
but I am currently-
- How do you wanna
get into it?
- Laughing at them.
- I don't know, I could
just start with one.
- Sure.
- So I kinda was thinking about things
that reliably make me laugh.
Like, I'll be honest.
I don't often make the
decision to be like,
I specifically want to laugh right now.
Like, that is not a-
- I really need to laugh.
I'm gonna go here. Yeah, I don't...
- That is not a common thing.
- I don't think like that, either.
- And we've talked about
this before on the show,
that we typically, when we think about...
If we're gonna commit
to a television show,
very rarely will it be a comedy.
Now, some comedies, I absolutely love,
but my favorite shows
are dramas, right?
Those are the things I kinda get lost in,
and even from movies,
I typically like a drama
more than I like a comedy.
I don't just make the choice to be like,
"Hey, let's watch this because the primary
intention is for us to
laugh," and I don't know...
I've heard that from a lot
of people who are comedians,
that they don't find their
entertainment in comedy
as much as they find it in other things,
'cause they're spending all day
doing things to make people laugh
or thinking about things
that make people laugh.
So I don't know, maybe that
has something to do with it.
- Maybe there's an element of work mode.
I think there's also an element of, like,
really escaping into a story
that you can really invest in
and put some time into.
And that level of escape is akin
to getting a laugh from something,
and-
- Right.
- But I do think I would
like to be a little more
intentional in not shying away
from seeking out laughter,
because it does the body good.
- Yeah.
- So if you were to go,
where would you go first?
- Well, just the other day,
we were here in the office-
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- Shooting some stuff, and
then we had a lunch break.
And sometimes we'll eat lunch
and not have a meeting
over lunch. (chuckles)
And this was one of those occasions,
so we could eat lunch and
just put something on the TV.
And I brought up, I think
the name of the video is,
"Vic Berger Presents the
Very Best of Jim Bakker."
Now you remember, if you
watched "Good Mythical Morning"
a couple of years ago,
(Link laughing)
Jim Bakker is the televangelist
who was really popular in
the '80s, he and Tammy Faye,
and they also, you know,
they were guilty of fraud,
and he took a bunch of money,
but he had this sort of redemption.
He went to prison and he came back
and he is, again, a televangelist.
And I think he's set up
in Branson, Missouri.
He invites these audiences
into his program.
He's got a new wife, who's
kinda Tammy Faye-like,
wears not as much makeup,
but she kinda serves the same role
that Tammy Faye served
for him back in the day.
And the thing that he
has gotten obsessed with,
as many televangelists
do, is the End Times.
And he's not just talking
about the End Times,
and the apocalypse
that's always impending.
He's also selling things that you can
prepare for the End Times with,
including-
- And survive.
- Jim Bakker Buckets,
which we taste-tested on
"Good Mythical Morning."
You should watch that
episode if you haven't.
- It's like a big five-gallon
plastic paint bucket,
but it's filled with
food, and on his show,
which he's got like a morning show set
and his wife is a cohost,
and he's got these
(chuckles) other cohosts,
and they've got a studio
audience that's sitting
in dinner place settings-
- Old folks, mostly.
- Yeah, and I mean, you'd
think he would open a bucket
and it would just be full
of creamed corn or potatoes,
because they make it in the
buckets and they stir it as if
they're feeding the 5,000!
- They present it in the most
unappetizing fashion imaginable,
including having a giant bucket of rice,
in which Jim Bakker
reaches his bare hand into
and just eats the rice.
Now, let me just say,
I could watch any of this
Jim Bakker programming,
unedited, just as it is,
and be very entertained.
And I have for...
I wanna be clear about this,
because you guys know our story,
you know that we were raised
in conservative Christianity,
evangelical Christianity,
and we're no longer a
part of that tradition.
I don't consider myself a
Christian at this point.
- It feels like maybe we're coming
after a preacher?
- But let me just
be very clear.
When I was a committed
evangelical Christian
on staff as a missionary with
a Christian organization,
I would still watch
guys like Kenneth Copeland, Jim Bakker-
- TBN network, yeah.
- For entertainment purposes.
Again, this is a little bit of
a deep cut, and it might be,
for those of you who don't come
from a Christian background,
you might be like, "What,
I don't understand?"
So when we were Christians,
we considered ourselves,
and I think rightly so,
a totally separate thing from
those televangelists, right?
And most Christians that I
know, that I'm friends with,
that I was friends with,
that I remain friends with to this day,
my family, everybody, they do not...
They think that those dudes
are a bunch of whack jobs.
- Kooky.
- So just to their credit,
they recognize that
these guys are swindlers,
these guys are about getting rich,
these guys are about taking
advantage of the vulnerable,
these guys are about making
these empty promises,
at least from the tradition
that we come from.
So, but I always got such a kick out of it
because you can't deny
the entertainment value
that these televangelists bring.
- Yeah, so there's no
agenda here to, like,
tear some sort of preacher apart-
- This is something that
I was thinking about
exactly the same way
that I think about now,
my entire life, just to be clear, but-
- And he has taken advantage
of people by, you know,
tapping into fear and
selling buckets of camp food
for thousands of dollars.
- Yeah.
- Trying to sell enough of
it that he's demonstrating
how you can turn the buckets
into furniture in your home.
- You just put a table top
over 'em, and then a curtain.
But Vic Berger, to give the-
- V-I-C B-E-R-G-E-R.
- To give the other side
of this. I don't really...
We've never met Vic before.
I don't even know if
that's his real name, but-
- We love him.
- He's been associated with
people like Tim and Eric,
and he was associated with Super Deluxe,
doing some stuff for them for a while.
But essentially, this guy is
the master of awkward edits,
of taking people who are genuinely already
funny and weird and awkward,
and then editing them in
a way that accentuates
that awkwardness to a complete new level.
The music and the edits and the way
that he kinda doubles back on things
and emphasizes things, and-
- It's a creative layer
that's editorial, in a sense that, like,
he's bringing his point of view to it
and adding another
layer, but you never lose
the initial magic.
- The purity.
- You can watch a Vic Berger edit
and appreciate the fact
that, yes, it's manipulated,
but the things that Jim Bakker
and his cohorts are saying
is not manipulated.
- I'm sure that if-
- He really said and did all these things,
and so, like you said, you
could just watch the show.
You need a little more patience.
And you have to get over the sadness
of him taking advantage of people.
But at a certain point,
especially with Vic's editions,
you can just embrace it
as this strange comedy!
- Well, I'll push back on
that getting over the sadness
of him taking advantage
of people, because-
- "Getting over it" is not the right word.
- I'll just say that I
think that the people
who are taken in by
people like Jim Bakker,
I don't have a lot of sympathy for them.
- Well, (sighs) you know-
- I'm just saying-
- That's harsh, because I mean,
you got some blue-haired
grannies, and it's just,
you know, you gotta protect those people.
You can't expect them-
- But hold on,
but what harm is being done to them?
- Money!
- They're not, I mean...
- They're being drained!
- Yeah, but they're, I mean...
- They're getting buckets
of food. (chuckles)
- I don't think people are going broke.
I don't think these old
folks are going broke
buying Jim Bakker Buckets, you know?
And I do think that-
- But they're scared
of the End Times, and they're-
- Well, and here-
- There's fear-mongering-
- I do think that,
and I do have, I don't
have Jim Bakker Buckets,
I have a fair amount, I
have a few months' supply
of freeze-dried food
at my house, you know?
And I got you some, and
that's probably the only...
You probably have like a couple
of weeks that I gave you.
- Thank you.
- But it isn't like selling a blessed...
And I don't know, Jim Bakker may do this,
but some people will sell
a blessed, you know, towel
that's got holy water on it.
And he's not, like, healing people.
He's not giving people false healing hope
and stuff like that.
Maybe he did that back in the day.
All I'm saying is,
I don't feel that bad
about that part of it,
because the worst thing that's happening
is some old folks are getting
more freeze-dried food
than they actually will use.
They're going to die,
and this stuff is gonna
be on their shelves
and get handed down to
the next generation, so-
- Well, listen, but the
one thing we can agree on
is that even though I feel
bad about it more so than you,
I feel sorry for these people.
It's so funny that you
can still get over it.
I can still get over it,
and we can agree on that,
how funny it is.
It's taking this reality and it's adding
this just creepy juxtapositions,
and you gotta watch it, but-
- And there's...
And I'm sure this is one of the things
that you're gonna talk about, no actor...
I'm not interested in an actor
portraying a Jim Bakker character.
Now, sure, I would
laugh at it. Like, okay-
- I'd pay a ticket price to watch
Sam Rockwell in a Jared Hess-
- Yeah, well, okay, I'm a fan-
- Which, that already exists,
by the way.
- I'm a fan
of "The Righteous
Gemstones," the HBO show,
which is different, but you
know, I'm a fan of that.
It's kind of making fun of that
kinda televangelist megachurch
culture in the South-
- But it's a totally different thing
when you know this is a dramatization.
They're actors.
- But I would much rather
see the real thing.
And I'm sure that...
Well, first of all, I know
that Jim Bakker and his wife,
and other people associated with him,
especially some of the younger people,
who are some of my
favorite people to watch
are the younger people who
are associated with it,
like onstage.
- Yeah.
- I know that they know
about the Vic Berger edits.
And you know that they're mad about them
because they think that
it misrepresents them,
and like you're saying, not
really, though. (laughs)
It's like, he's taking all the things
that you said and you did,
and he's putting them together, and yes,
he's manipulating the edit
and if this was in a court of law,
this would not be admissible evidence,
but you're laughing at the
things that actually happened,
in the juxtaposition of them.
- Yeah, we have this shared
fascination with people being real.
I mean, (chuckles) you
know that as a family,
we've dedicated our lives
to watching "Survivor."
That is like our life-
- It's the funniest show
on television.
(both laughing)
- But you know what, one of
the things that I love about it
is that when you get some
really good characters,
which is basically just people
who are unabashedly strange,
and they can't hide it, you know,
out there on the island,
your soul is bared.
Your personality, like all
of your defense mechanisms,
everything you do, it's just...
I love the psychological analysis of that.
And some people are really funny
and they do a good job,
an Emmy-winning job,
of editing these characters.
And especially because
they're put in situations
that aren't romantic.
That's actually, you know,
there's so much of that out there.
That's why I love "Survivor,"
is that you're seeing
real people, and sometimes
really strange people,
being pushed to their limits,
and it's not about
making out with somebody.
Now, I know that that's
also entertaining for you,
and you really get into it.
- That, but, well,
I'm not into "90 Day Fiance"
because of the making out, trust me,
or "The Bachelor," for that-
- It's for the comedy.
- It's for the putting
normal people in a situation...
In an abnormal situation, really.
For me, it's the same principle.
I also enjoy, I enjoy "Survivor."
We don't watch it
religiously, but yeah, I-
- It's not a comedy, but...
- Yeah, but I enjoy the trashy
reality shows more because the people
are more extreme.
Like, that's the thing. Jim Bakker...
I have complicated feelings
towards Jim Bakker,
because he creeps me out in a certain way,
but at the same time,
something about the way
(laughs) his eyes move
and his mouth, the position that he has,
and the way that he expresses things,
is incredibly endearing.
- These are things that
just happen on his face.
- (laughs) Yeah!
- He hasn't...
You can tell that he
hasn't watched himself back
and become a persona.
A lot of, I think, televangelists,
I think they do that;
there's a performance as...
And of course, he's a
performer too, he's a host,
he's been on television-
- But he's not polished or slick.
- Yeah, but so much of
it is still instinctive.
Like, why is his face
doing that right now?
- Right, and if he was your granddad-
- It's the granddad energy.
- You would find all those weird things,
like his fashion sense,
like the fact that he...
He's got that hat with the cross on it,
and then he's got these
vests that he'll wear
that look like he's going fly fishing,
but he's not, he's just hosting a show.
These little choices
that he's making-
- Lotta empty pockets.
- I just, I find it intoxicating. (laughs)
You know what I'm saying?
- It's great.
- And the process of
someone trying to be funny,
and again, this goes back to why,
when we made the local
commercials, we were so into it,
'cause you take like Goorgon, you know,
from the "Shift It, Shift It" commercial,
and the entertainment quality for us
was based in getting Goorgon
to make a commercial.
You know what I'm saying? It was like-
- Well, and it was also very...
Well, what do you mean...
Well, it was very
important that we preserve
and platform the strangest
parts of our clients
that were actually real.
- Well, but also-
- We didn't manufacture
a personality for them.
- Like the scene where he
is answering the phone, but he hesitated,
and he-
- Yeah.
- We didn't fully direct him.
When you wanna get these type
of performances out of people,
you direct them enough to
push them in a direction-
- To see what they would do.
- But then you let them direct themselves.
So it was like, he... (laughs)
I can't remember, I think
he picks up the phone
and says something, and then-
- No, he's on the phone,
and he sees the woman drive up.
- Oh yeah, but he didn't know
if he should keep the
phone up or put it down.
And there's like hesitation.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- And it's like, we see that kinda thing,
and we're like, that's the gold.
That's what we want. I don't know...
And I can't really express, I
can't articulate what it is,
but for me-
- Honest.
- There's this, yeah, relatable
honesty in that moment,
of, he's like, "I don't know what to do
with the phone."
(Link laughing)
And we're like, "Well,
that's why this is going
in the commercial."
- And it kinda worked from
a story standpoint, too,
that, like, I know, he
sees this beautiful woman,
who just responded to a
Craigslist ad, (laughs)
to show up and be in his commercial.
But, like, oh, you know,
he's bumfuzzled. (laughs)
On a couple of...
That's what it seems like from a character
standpoint he's doing, but
you know, at the same time,
that he's not an actor,
and he's doing this...
I mean, I know you wanna talk
about ""Family Feud," right?
There's a connection to that!
- Yeah, so another thing that I'll do
is watch compilations
of "Family Feud" stuff-
- Yeah,
we've done this for years.
- But more recently,
I've been watching just whole
episodes of the "Family Feud."
Now, is it as good as the compilations?
It's not as concentrated, by any means.
- Sure.
- But you actually get
into the gameplay, and my
family and I will sit down.
You guys are watching "Survivor."
The McLaughlins are
watching "Family Feud."
And being committed to the gameplay,
like really, everyone's trying to answer.
Everybody's saying the answer,
and we're getting into it,
and then I find myself
doing this same thing.
So one of the classic
things in "Family Feud" is,
after the round has been completed
and there's still some
unrevealed answers on the board,
they reveal them, and then the crowd just-
- Reads out loud.
- Impulsively repeats it.
You know, it's like, we asked 100 people,
"What's the first thing
you put on in the morning?"
"Underwear!" Everybody says that.
And I find myself watching
it and saying, "Underwear!"
- You speak out loud?
- Yes, I am a-
- Wow.
- I am a committed audience member,
and then I'm like-
- Yeah, you are.
- Okay, what is Steve
gonna do? Steve's gonna...
Okay, oh, he's all over this one.
They're gonna say this...
He's gonna make fun of this guy.
Oh, he's gonna pull back a little bit
'cause this girl's not
responding that well to this.
And also, the producers
making the decision,
the whole system of "Family
Feud" is now designed
to create YouTube clips.
So it's gotten way more suggestive.
Because it used to be
accidentally suggestive,
and then they were just like,
"Let's just go all the way,
and let's just ask questions."
Sometimes they can go-
- And they can get
embarrassing answers.
- A little too far
and it seems too forced,
but again, it's also,
I'm fascinated by, these
people playing this game
have never been on television.
And I'm thinking about what
is going through this...
Like, this dad brings his family,
and he's thinking 17 things.
He's thinking, I'm on television,
I don't wanna be an idiot.
I might end up being on
YouTube. I wanna win the money.
I wanna beat that other family.
I gotta think about the
actual way that people
would've answered this.
- Yeah, it's tough.
- And I'm fascinated
by the honest human psychology
of somebody being on a game show!
- Yeah, and it's a brilliant setup,
because once you have all of
that going through your mind,
and then Steve Harvey's in your
face asking you a question,
that surreal experience-
- You're like, I'm there now.
- Then you...
You can't manufacture responses!
You end up just saying
the first thing that comes to your mind,
you know, you're playing the game,
but, like, you're playing
it in this kinda weakened,
laid-bare state, where
it's like, you can't...
There's the self-preservation, you know,
that quotient has gone
to nil by this point.
And it's the perfect recipe
for people to embarrass
themselves with honesty.
Honesty! I think that's-
- Yeah, it's great.
- That's what we go back to.
- And you've got somebody, Steve Harvey,
the reason that he's such a good host
is because he's incredibly honest.
So, like, you can't say
something that's a dumb answer,
and not have him point it out,
and not have him drag you.
And some people might be like,
"Well, that's kind of unfair," it's like,
you know what you're getting into!
You know, chill out a little bit.
You know what you're getting
into when you go on that show.
And the thing is, is that in the same...
You know how you and I, we
make observations about people.
We've talked about this many times,
where we'll go to a party, whatever,
we have an interaction with somebody,
and there'll be something
specific about a person,
just something notable about them.
And then we'll get into the car, go home,
and be like, "Hey, when
we talked to that guy,
what did you notice about
him?" and then we'll be like...
We have fun figuring out, well,
what was it that you noticed about him?
It was his jacket, or it was the way
he pointed at somebody
when he talking to them,
you know, some specific thing.
We're fascinated by that element
of human behavior.
- Was he winking?
Or was there something in his eye?
- And Steve Harvey will not let
you get away with something.
He points it out and
then he can (chuckles)
be funny about it in the moment,
that's what makes him good.
Every "Family Feud" host
has been able to do that.
- But the observational sense of humor
does make me think of "Seinfeld."
That was our favorite sitcom growing up.
It was unlike any sitcom before it.
But it's taking...
You could tell when you were
watching these characters,
and everything that happened,
that it was Larry David and Jerry Seinfeld
pumping these characters full
of their observational humor.
So yeah, you're one step removed
in that these are actors,
but the subject matter was
still that observational honesty
and exploring that stuff, and then,
with a character like Kramer,
or a lot of the characters,
yeah, it was the other characters
kinda picking them apart,
Jerry picking apart his dates,
then everyone picking
apart Elaine's dates,
including Elaine, you know?
And, well, they picked apart everybody
that was outside of their circle,
which I think is something
that maybe we enjoyed
and then adopted in our friendship,
in sort of picking apart other things.
- But they were all assholes.
- Yeah.
- All of 'em, all four of the main cast.
- Who never changed.
- Well, Kramer wasn't-
- No, he wasn't, yeah.
- As much, but,
they were all assholes, but...
And that's one of the
reasons people didn't think
that it would work, it's like,
well, who likes these people?
And it also might be
one of the reasons that-
- But I didn't like-
- The younger generation
watches it now and it's
like, well, first of all,
you have to get over the '90s of it,
and the laugh track and all that stuff,
that might get in the way.
- But it wasn't that
I liked them first; I
understood how they thought.
- Right. Yeah, exactly!
- And then you start
to like them as people
when you start to appreciate more of it.
But, you know, I was thinking about, like,
what are the shows I'll watch now?
I watched "Ted Lasso"
and I really liked it.
- But not necessarily for the comedy.
I mean there were
definitely funny moments.
I liked it for the heart.
- Yeah, for the heart, I
think it was, you know,
I really enjoyed how the characters
all went on journeys, and yeah,
I don't think it was first
and foremost the comedy
that made me love the show.
It took a while to get into it.
There was like some hokey
situations or whatever, but-
- Some of my least favorite
parts of "Ted Lasso"
are some of the jokes that don't work.
- Now, I think, I think
Ted Lasso as a character-
- Oh, yeah.
- Like, he worked.
He was locked in.
- I loved the show.
- He was locked in.
It was the people around
him and the type of jokes.
But, you know, as we've talked
about the things that we like the most,
like when I think of television,
I think of "Seinfeld,"
I think of "The Office," and
then when I think of movies,
and I try to draw some
conclusions from this,
the type of comedy movies that we like...
The Adam Sandler movies,
even the Will Ferrell movies,
that type of stuff that
was like over the top,
I watched some of those, but
I never really got into it.
The type of comedies
that I really got into
were like the Coen brothers comedies,
and then trying to figure out,
why is it that I thought
"The Big Lebowski"
was so much funnier than, well,
I was gonna say "Talladega Nights,"
but that's a really funny movie.
- I think, well-
- That one's an exception
because it-
- I also think
that Will Ferrell and Adam Sandler,
it's a very different approach.
- Yeah, once I began to appreciate
the Adam McKay of it all,
and once he started to create
so many other Oscar-worthy movies,
is that, like, I started to reassess
how I'd written off those
Will Ferrell movies.
And I do think that they're great.
But I think that the
thing that I was drawn to,
and I think both of us, and
that we've talked about,
is, well, we definitely don't like
these joke-oriented sitcoms.
We like more of the
situational-oriented sitcoms,
and have that different single-cam tone,
versus the multi-cam "Big Bang Theory,"
like, every word out of
their mouth is a joke,
and everything is just a setup
for them to get to tell more jokes.
And realizing that
didn't resonate with me,
but seeing what was different
about the things that did,
and I think one of the
things that I concluded was,
I mean, having characters
that are built funny that I could...
I think that there's something to that
in what we've already talked about,
about our fascination with
the comedy and real people.
Like a really well-built
comedic character,
take any character from
"The Big Lebowski."
I think it applies.
And then you put those type of characters
in situations that are
funny and then let them say
what they would say and do and
respond in those situations,
and that's-
- And it will be funny.
I love that, as opposed to
the joke-oriented stuff,
when it's like, all of
this is just a setup
so they can say things that are funny,
and then it's all about, well,
did I laugh at that joke or not?
And did I laugh at a high
enough percentage of the jokes
to think this movie was good?
- I think it's when you can sense
the presence of the writer,
it's a turnoff, right?
- For us, yeah.
- Yeah, and when you say
funny situations versus jokes-
- When we first talked about that,
we thought it was like a revelation.
It seems pretty obvious.
- No, but I think the way
that you broke it down is exactly right.
It's funny people being
put in funny situations,
and they will say memorable, funny things,
but it's not jokes, and it might...
Okay, so you take something...
One of my favorite shows, "Barry," right?
"Barry" on HBO, Bill
Hader plays, basically,
a hitman who's trying to-
- Become an actor.
- And it has one of our
favorite actors in it, Stephen Root.
It kinda toes the line, right?
There are some ridiculous characters
that say things that no one
would ever actually say,
no matter who they were, you
put them in this situation,
okay this, that was a writer's idea
of what would be a funny thing to say.
That was a joke; that was a
setup, that was a punchline.
It happens, and you know what,
when they go a little bit
too far, I don't like it,
but I love the show
because they don't do it
very often-
- Oh, the way we put it
was choices-
- Yeah, funny choices
versus jokes.
- Yes. It's like, so...
It's kinda like behind the scenes with...
The brilliance of
"Barry" is that you take,
you build these characters,
you put 'em in this high-stakes situation,
but you tweak everything for the comedy.
Everything that, it could be, I mean,
this could be Kiefer Sutherland in "24."
You can have the same
characters in the same story,
but the way that all the situations
are turned towards comedy to
kinda skewer the acting world
and acting classes and
just the situations,
the irony of somebody who is a killer
trying to become an actor.
We just can sense those funny...
The choices set up the comedy, not the...
And then you trust the payoff,
versus writing the joke,
the punchline as a payoff.
- And in the stuff
that we're currently working on,
which we continue to
develop and write things
that we really hope
you'll see at some point,
but that's really what we're focusing on.
Now, I don't-
- it's so important,
the beginning is so important
to us for those reasons,
'cause then you trust that
if you set it up right,
that the comedy will take care of itself.
- And let me just be clear,
this is not what we did on "Buddy System."
Season one, which we always sorta
dog a little bit and say isn't any good,
(sighs) it's not great.
It had some jokes in it that didn't land.
We kinda did the funny situation thing.
Second season, we like better
because it was better executed,
it was a better story,
we were playing characters.
We weren't just playing ourselves.
But it was absurdist,
and also, it did have...
Many things that were
said and done were things
that no one would ever say and do.
And I think that it worked and
I do like absurdist comedy,
and I even like sitcoms at times.
But none of the stuff that we're currently
working on plays in that world.
Right now, everything that
we're working on is like,
these characters are funny.
This situation that we're putting them in-
- Is dramatic.
- Is going to draw
out the funny, because as
they navigate this world,
or this serious situation
or this perilous situation,
they're gonna end up saying
and doing funny things,
because that's the way
the characters are built,
but we're gonna try to authentically
represent what we think this character
would actually do in this situation.
And that's kind of a big shift
for us creatively, right?
Because again, when you
think about what we do
and the sort of sketches that we put out
on Instagram or TikTok
or that kinda thing,
it's like, those are, it's a
completely different medium.
The conceit is, we're in a comical,
ridiculous, nonbelievable world.
So, and it's a totally different thing.
The stuff that we're
working on narratively,
like longer-form stuff,
is in that sort of more authentic place.
- But let's go to the
social media of it all,
because, I mean...
I mean, of course my
kids only go to TikTok,
and so much of that is comedy, you know?
And they're just sitting there laughing
and sharing stuff with each other.
- And I think the reason
that, I'll show...
And I know you know the guy
that I'm gonna talk about,
'cause you think he's funny as well,
I think the thing that
makes a funny TikTok for me,
and again, this is obviously
completely scripted,
because in the example that
we're gonna talk about,
in many examples, it's one
person playing every single role,
so it's obviously fake
and obviously written.
It's a narrative thing.
It's the very specific
choices that make it
feel like fresh comedy.
It makes it feel like
somebody is kinda pushing
into a new sort of boundary
and a new way of thinking about comedy,
or there's just something
about this person
that is just intrinsically funny.
So I'm gonna talk about
Petey USA.
(Link chuckles)
So P-E-T-E-Y U-S-A,
long-haired, bearded guy.
I mean, he's only got-
- How many followers
does he got?
- 585,000 followers
at the time of this recording.
And listen, I don't know
anything about this guy.
All I know is his TikToks,
and I find his TikToks very funny.
So I'm just gonna, let's just...
Did you see the one about cornhole?
- Yeah. I've seen a lot of
these. I really like him.
- Okay, well, let's just
watch the one about cornhole.
- And I mean, he's playing this...
Petey USA is this character,
but something about the fact
that you don't know what you're gonna get
when you scroll across TikTok.
You wanna believe that
this is a real person.
He does such a good job in his portrayal,
that, I mean, the nature of
the comedy is so strange,
that you know that it's intentional,
but it's also so strange
that it must've come
from a really strange person,
so you start to think that
this guy's self-aware enough
to tap into his strangeness.
But I think there's a lot of the real guy-
- Definitely! Definitely.
- Out front here.
So even that, trying to
parse that, is fascinating.
- He's not trying to be
somebody who he's not.
He's trying to be an
elevated version of himself.
Okay, let's watch this one about cornhole.
- Mkay.
(cornbag thuds)
Playing cornhole.
- Dammit.
- Oh, a hand comes out of the cornhole,
takes his corn bag-
- What the fuck?
(quiet music)
- It's kinda creepy.
- Hey, man!
- Oh, it's him,
in the cornhole.
- How'd you get in there?
I'm cut in half, man.
Oh my god!
- He's cut in half.
- How are you not even bleeding?
Oh, I'm bleeding pretty good, actually.
Oh, fuck! You need to go-
- Yeah, he's got blood
all over the place.
- To the hospital.
- I love the fact that
when he says expletives,
he beeps it out,
but you can still hear it.
- You still hear it.
- He's making all these choices.
- Hey, what's goin' on out there?
- Now he comes out of the house.
- A third version of himself.
- Is he bleeding?
Yeah, he's bleeding pretty good.
What's he doing in the cornhole?
He just wanted to do a little goof
before he passed on.
- It's just such a strangely
normal conversation.
- A little goof.
- Pretty good, actually!
Does he want a soda or anything?
I got some in the fridge.
I'll ask him. Hey man, do you want a...
- Oh no, he's dead.
- Aw, geez.
What's up?
I think he just passed away.
- (chuckles) Passed away.
- Yeah, he's passed on,
unfortunately.
- (laughs) Passed on!
- Well, you know, cut-in-half
guys tend to do that.
Yeah, half a guy doesn't tend
to last too long, does he?
(Rhett laughing)
- That's the end.
That's the end?
- So, just, that's it!
- Yeah, "Half a guy doesn't
tend to last too long, does he?"
I mean, where...
Who comes up with this stuff?
- Petey does.
- How does Petey
come up with this stuff?
It's brilliant! I mean, I can see this...
If I met this guy and
he was totally normal,
I would believe it.
I mean, the performance
could be that masterful.
He could be somewhere in the middle
and there could be a lot of
strangeness in his real persona.
But I can definitely see
him showing up in movies.
It has to already be happening.
- Sure, yeah, sure.
- He has to be on sets-
- He's going to auditions.
- Playing this character.
- Let's watch another one.
I don't even know which one this is.
It just has 3 million
views, so it must be good.
- Play. See?
(gentle music)
- Okay, so he's watching-
- It's guys swimming.
- He's watching guys swimming-
- WTF, this is sick.
- In an Olympic pool, with himself.
- Hey, what's up, guys?
Hey, what's up?
- And then he comes in.
- You got it, man.
Epic, hold their breath?
They hold their breath underwater
(Rhett laughing)
and then they do one of these.
What's goin' on?
- He's acting like a swimmer.
Hey, man. Hey.
Hey, man!
- None of these guys
have ever seen swimmers.
- Guys swimming, yeah.
Epic!
- Yeah.
- Holding their breath?
They're fascinated by it.
- Doing one of these guys.
No way!
- No way. Five of them.
- It's guys swimming.
Like fish?
Well, yeah, but they're guys.
Incredible.
(Rhett laughing)
Guys swimming like fish.
- (laughs) Now they're
slapping fives with each other.
- I mean, the editing is so great,
because it's just one guy!
- And the music.
- The music is strange.
(hands slapping)
- Swimming guys.
Exactly, man.
- They're still giving fives.
- It's like, what?
- (laughs) I mean-
- And that's it.
- It's just, I just-
- So, footage of swimmers-
- It's just, they're watching-
- Turns into-
- Two guys swimming.
- "They" meaning him playing
five different characters-
- Everybody in the same-
- Which, in the same...
They're all the same guy-
- They're just dressed
differently.
- In different clothes.
(laughs) He's so great!
- And he puts his music,
this like (hums weirdly),
this weird ethereal music
underneath everything,
that is also a very specific
and wonderful choice.
- It's just so fresh.
I think that's the thing
that I love about it
is that I can't compare it to any other
comedic sensibility.
It's out of left field,
so it surprises you and it
makes you feel a little envious.
Like, I know that I could never, you know,
I could never be that guy,
but I'd like to have that ability.
- Well, I think that,
yeah, we have a tendency...
Again, I think that Petey is...
This is calculated, of course.
He knows why it's funny.
He's self-aware enough
to know why he's funny,
but you can tell, just
like you said earlier,
if you met this dude,
the way that he would
interact with you is like
one of these characters-
- I don't know anymore.
- No, what I'm saying is, like,
I mean, that's his haircut.
He has chosen to have that
long hair in that way, right?
That's a choice.
- You know, he could be in an
Allman Brothers cover band.
- Right, but...
And I think that there is
this, like, yeah, okay,
well, we would have to
play some kind of character
in order to achieve this, and
at that point, it would...
This is one of the things that's happening
with comedy in general, right?
So there is this, in a good way,
this new appreciation for authenticity.
Again, he is playing a character
and he's coming up with these situations,
that, I'm not saying
that he would just bond
with some dude over guys
swimming in that way.
It's clearly a joke,
it's clearly elevated,
and it's clearly scripted.
But that thing you're talking about
is this authenticity of...
It's the same reason that people
are so into commentary videos right now,
is because I'm watching someone-
- Honestly process-
- Process something,
and if they're really funny
and they make really funny
observations about it,
they're kind of interacting with it
in the way that I want to
interact with this stuff.
- The best commentators are the ones
that you never get a sense
they're trying too hard.
That's absolutely something
that we have, you know,
that we've had a problem with all along,
is just trying too hard, pushing too hard.
And you know, I think once we've...
I mean, we're still relaxing
into "Good Mythical Morning,"
and I'm encouraged, and I think
people are picking up on it,
that we're just, we're pushing things
less and less and just saying,
"You know what, we're just going with it."
And if we do something
where we are pushing
the comedy of something,
I think that you can
tell, or they can tell,
that it's more from a place of, like,
we're just motivated to wanna do it.
We're not trying to achieve something
or get something out of somebody.
We think it's funny and so we're just
screwing around with each other.
I think that level of
authenticity is something,
after all these years,
we're still working at,
and still homing.
You know, another-
- Well, no,
that would be honing.
That is the one...
- (sighs) Oh, shit.
- You actually...
Yeah, if you're still working
on it, you're still honing it.
- I'm still working on
the use of that term.
- You can just use honing
in all situations, though.
- Well-
- That's what you concluded
before, and then you just
went back on yourself.
- It's your fault.
(Rhett chuckling)
You get in my head, man!
I mean-
- Still homing.
- The other show that I
like, the HBO show "How To,"
with John, what's his last name?
- Yeah.
- I'd like to look it up.
I can't remember
his frickin' last name.
- I'll put it on my list of...
We're having a creative
little meeting later today.
- Yeah, it's on my list.
- It's on my list, yeah.
Of favorite shows.
- Look up his freaking last name,
'cause as much as I love the show,
I hate the fact that I can't
remember right now.
- Well, I've got it.
I've got it on my list.
- Yeah, it's so, I mean,
he films-
- Wilson, John Wilson.
- "How To with John Wilson," he films...
He's got reams of footage from his life
living around New York City,
and then he turns it into these...
He pieces it together as
these narratives, kinda.
There's your stories
that you're following.
There's ideas that he's exploring,
and there's lots of left turns.
So it's not a beginning, middle, and end.
It's a beginning, a
left turn, a left turn,
look at where we ended up,
you loved every second of it.
- But we have a difference
of opinion, I think,
on just how authentic he is.
How much is he the guy that
he is presenting himself,
and how much is calculated?
I think it's more calculated than you,
last time we talked about it,
at least.
- Yeah, I'm on the opposite
side of Petey USA than you.
- But this is good,
because this is exactly what...
First of all, I don't
care how calculated it is,
because the final product is believable.
- Right.
- And that is how I think
that all this move towards authenticity
that's taking place in the creator-driven,
entertainment system that is
TikTok, YouTube, whatever,
it's not going to do
away with larger-budget,
produced, scripted content.
It just influences it, and
the way that it influences it
is the stuff that we're talking about,
which is really good...
It's why comedians have
to be better actors
than they had to be 20 years ago, I think,
in order to make the kind
of comedy that I wanna see.
And that is because you
need to be able to get me
to buy into the authenticity, the reality,
of the character that you're portraying.
And then I can feel free to laugh.
But the moment that I feel
like I sense the actor
and I sense the writing,
which is something that no one cared about
when Chevy Chase was doing it in the '80s.
And again, you can still go
back and enjoy all those things,
legitimately enjoy
Chevy Chase in the '80s.
I'm not saying it's not funny,
but the reason that you
can't just do that now
is 'cause people are
viewing all that old stuff
through the lens of nostalgia
and you're appreciating it
and you're giving it
the benefit of the doubt
because of what it was.
But nowadays, I do think the stuff that...
I think that it isn't some grand
calculation that we've made.
I think that we're
responding to the environment
of the comedy that we're
into and is around us.
And we're like, this has gotta
be, it has to feel authentic.
That doesn't mean that somebody
is not gonna be a character actor.
is not gonna play a
completely different person.
It doesn't mean that
somebody is going to be...
You take Christopher Guest, I mean,
one of the reasons that that
stuff holds up for me...
We watched "Best in Show"-
- All the mockumentaries.
- We watched "Best in Show"
a couple of weeks ago,
me and Jesse and Shepherd, and
Shepherd absolutely loved it.
And you know, you take the character
that Christopher Guest
plays in that movie,
which is (laughs) obviously-
- The hound dog guy?
- The hound, it's not him,
it's this dude from some
place in North Carolina,
but I can't remember, I
think it was a made-up name.
Pine Tree? Pine Nut, North Carolina.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- But everyone plays-
- That's so good.
- Those characters
so authentically-
- What does he list out?
He lists out different types of-
- Types of nuts.
- You got pine nuts, you got peanuts,
you got almonds nuts, you got...
- And he loves those dogs.
- Yeah, but the reason that he's funny-
- Is 'cause you can tell
it's Christopher Guest
doing this off the top of his head.
- But he's also tapping into something
that is representative of
something that is real and exists.
- Yeah, which is why "Talladega Nights"
is kinda like the outlier
Will Ferrell movie for me,
because I knew how true it was.
And it was actually a lot
more grounded than someone
who didn't live, you know,
grow up around where we did,
would think that it was
just too ridiculous,
but it was actually more grounded.
- Truth, I mean, there's
all kinds of theories
about what makes something funny,
and philosophers have
been debating it forever,
but I always kinda
gravitate towards this idea
that the truth...
There's truth in comedy,
and that's the thing that
you're kinda connecting with.
And you can get to truth through things
that are absurd and completely unreal,
like we both are huge fans
of "The Mighty Boosh,"
and nothing that happens
in "The Mighty Boosh" is...
It's almost like you can't...
You have to pick a side
of the argument, right?
You have to be like, I'm
going to try to be authentic
and represent the truth in a
way that you'll find relatable,
or I'm gonna be so far
removed from your own
understanding and
experience that you'll be...
It's almost, there's an uncanny valley,
I think, between absurdist and realist,
that I just don't...
- Yeah, like-
- If you live in the uncanny valley,
you can't get into it.
- I love "Rick and Morty."
I mean, the absurdist nature
of "Rick and Morty," I mean,
as an animated show, I guess,
as an old fart like me,
it's like you have that suspension
of disbelief, and like...
But yeah, "The Mighty Boosh" did that too,
where it was like, you're
just gonna embrace the crazy.
When you talk about the
evolution of comedy,
and of television, I mean,
it does make me think
of like the brilliance of "WandaVision,"
and how I noticed that I enjoyed
the later episodes better
because they were...
It was easier to enjoy them
because the form was something
that was closer to-
- It's more familiar.
- It was more, well, it was more-
- [Both] Real.
- Because of that trajectory
that you're describing in comedy
applies to television in general.
You know, I think about,
if you go back to the...
If you showed, just to, even...
If you showed an episode
of "Modern Family,"
which is still very heightened, you know,
but if you go back and you show that
to someone from the 1950s,
and you remove the shock
of technology and culture,
and you just made it about
like the way they were acting?
By the way, I think that's one of the...
"WandaVision" was just a
ballsy move, what they did,
and like I told you, I
think that going back
and watching it just to
appreciate the acting
and how they acted within
the different eras,
was pretty brilliant.
- And especially-
- But I don't know how-
- Who's the supporting actor in that?
Who plays her friend?
- Agatha.
- Yeah, who plays Agatha-
- I don't-
- She's fabulous.
- Kathryn...
Whatever her name is,
she does that perfectly.
She embodies those stereo...
I mean, Elizabeth Olsen is great in it,
but Kathryn what's-her-name (chuckles)
is perfect in the way
that she's able to embody
those different tropes.
- But yeah, I think we're getting, I mean,
if you continue the trajectory,
and there's so many
comedies now that are...
They're dramedies, you know?
That resonates so much with us,
where you can put funny
people in real situations
and you can have it all,
you can have comedy in all those things.
- Right.
- Now what?
- Well, I mean, I think we've...
I don't know if we've learned anything,
established anything,
or if you've gotten anything from this.
It was a fun conversation, though.
- Yeah, thanks for having
it. Thanks for being here.
- And I can close with a
rec that I've already...
Anything that I talked about is a rec,
but I will say that if
you want like a 45-minute,
uninterrupted,
just-sit-back-enjoy-it experience,
just google "Vic Berger Presents:
The Very Best of Jim Bakker," and it is...
It's just delightful to me!
(Link laughing)
- Check it out.
#EarBiscuits to let us
know what you thought
about this conversation, and you know,
where you go for laughs.
(upbeat music)
Especially if you come to us for laughs,
I'm interested in the
other places that you go.
- Yeah, what's the Venn
diagram in your life,
the comedy Venn diagram?
- Hmm.
We'll talk at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)